[Music]
did an idiot suggest
you should steal from cvs another out of
touch celebrity
made some dumb ass comments which means
it's time for a new segment called
idiot says what
sex and the city actress and failed
gubernatorial candidate cynthia nixon
says poor people should be allowed to
steal personal goods from stores
between her and cuomo i haven't heard of
a choice this bad outside of states that
let inmates choose how they're executed
the about democratic socialist tweeted a
cvs on my
corner has started locking up basic
items like clothing detergent
and so as many families can't make ends
meet right now i can't imagine thinking
that the ways to solve the problem of
people stealing basic necessities
out of desperation is to prosecute them
you're right so how about an express
aisle for people only stealing 10 items
i can't imagine thinking a business can
stay open when shoplifters help
themselves
she's more out of touch with reality
than miranda was when she thought steve
could change
sex in the city reference nixon lives in
manhattan but in san francisco walgreens
has had to close
10 locations at least due to rampant
unchecked
shoplifting now they're the only ones in
the bay area not selling drugs
tyrus how stupid can this person be
there are the people that are stealing
from cvs
it's actually organized retail crime
they go in
they're young they steal and that's it
it's no poor people
i pisses me off it's it's literally goes
back to that
same liberal thinking
i'm not affected by this yeah so instead
of you donating to a cause or starting a
charity or you may be taking one of your
royalty checks from what was it hugs in
the city
and buy a bunch of medication and maybe
show up and hand them out in a truck
like people do with turkeys
instead of that you know what they
should do it's no different than saying
let them eat bread
let them rob people who are working
every day
to pay their bills and so let's just
take from them because i'm not giving
anything but it's that
type of out of touch stupidity that we
just see and then
because they're a celebrity and smile
afterwards and have a good eight by ten
we're supposed to repeat it
you know i don't know if that's a good
eight by ten it doesn't it doesn't
matter like
like the thing is it's not even she ran
for governor so
even the celebrity thing is she actually
thought she could be governor
and she and to your point she is a white
leftist and the people being hurt by
this idea
are minority families that live near a
cva like in san francisco in that
neighborhood
poor families and elderly are now going
to have to walk where to the next cvs
and maybe maybe a neighborhood that's
not that safe
she makes it's her mentality that drives
that yeah and also
if you allow people to steal things the
prices go way higher so
poor people who don't steal would have
to pay a lot more but look everything
about this was ridiculous so it's easy
to miss perhaps the most ridiculous
thing of all
which is her suggestion that she
actually went to a cvs
to pick up some laundry detergent for
herself that never happened
he's getting 10 million dollars for the
sex and the city reboot
how much 10 million for the reason he's
the least likable character
i could see carrie getting ten for
miranda no
and what about steve i've actually
never seen this this is an actual show
yeah yeah
the show well i don't know what's gotten
into me lately but that was wrong what i
just did
uh where were we i just i don't think
that she actually
walked to the store to get her own
laundry detergent someone should ask her
what it costs
by the way so when you go to any
drugstore
in any major city they have to lock up
the
the razors right because razors are
correct and every time you go in there
there's something else that's locked up
because
only high-priced items that could be
resold on the street
are it's not people going i need a loaf
of bread because you can get a loaf of
bread free
you can you just go to the the churches
have have these uh you know
no one's starving in these cities this
is retail theft
yes and this is such a saviorist
mentality this is the
total mental illness from the a block
literally
it's so embarrassing meanwhile she's
prancing around the upper east side
being like
let the poor still their detergent and
everyone else is like
it's not a crime why have you hit that
voice
all these years i don't know i i black
people don't talk like that every day
and meanwhile it's just it's just a
crime to shoplift and the worst thing to
me actually
was the fact that she drew an
equivalence between locking up items and
prosecution like i am happy to show
miranda anytime what a real prosecution
looks like
because believe me sister having to ask
the clerk for a key to the razor is not
it
yeah and she equates
[Laughter]
i can't even do it again that voice and
outnumbered tomorrow show
yes with it every time
pete that's a really good but she also
equates um the poor
with an acceptance of thievery it's like
all all poor people would do this
right it's like if they need something
they'll just go and take it the poor
people
in this story are actually the
capitalists treating cvs as their
storage warehouse
right because they're stealing the stuff
going out on the street and then selling
it i know
that's exactly what they're doing no
it's true
about it yes this is someone who's
absolutely never run a business
wouldn't wouldn't factor that in is
dealing with uh the
mental i mean leftism is a mental
illness we know that uh is dealing
managing that in real time so we should
feel for her that way and she does
reflect i mean she could be governor or
mayor and govern
as well as these left-wing democrats are
doing in cities and states right now san
francisco it's actually 17 walgreens in
the last five years
17 in the last five years have closed
because they can't keep
anything under 950 dollars it's only a
misdemeanor
right to steal it 950 bucks you got to
work hard into walgreens yeah
find something that costs nine hundred
gotta be it's gotta be violence
gonna happen with store clerks trying to
stop them yeah yeah right so they don't
they won't that's why that's why this is
happening nobody can do anything
except clothes and the boys lose their
jobs hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else